i don't talk about sex on this podcast
very much i don't know why because i
think most people think that's like my
thing
but i wanted to talk to you about
is it true that you were dominatrix at
one point in your life yeah i'm like not
a good one though like i um
like can i
whip you yeah yeah are you like okay so
about like
asking permission but also i'm like kind
of lazy and you know when you're a
dominatrix you have to be able to
get into their head and
know how to push their boundaries and
you know you got to be like a good one
like it's
it's worth all the money that people pay
them i have a friend that does this as
well and she was like i'm sure
to me i'm always just fascinated by like
human nature and when sex is sexual and
when it's not and
you know what our sort of
needs behind closed doors mean about us
and i feel like lately i've been dealing
with a little bit of shame with wanting
very aggressive a very aggressive man
and there is this shame of like oh i'm
like not a good woman if i want to be
choked or i'm not a good woman if i want
a man to like
boss me around or whatever but i think
there's just something interesting going
on right now where a lot of women i know
are like is it okay to like
have these fantasies where i'm getting
choked and what you know it's just like
in and i'm just curious like what you've
learned about like human nature and
what
invisible wounds yield what kind of
sexual needs you know well i think what
it is is that when you're really good at
work and you're really good at life you
want somebody to
be able to come in and
um
uh be able to override that sexually so
when you're submissive sexually
generally what it means is that you're
powerful in your daily life so that's
why most ceos want to get peed on people
who are powerful
generally
want to be dominated and
i mean it's just as true for women as it
is for men i think even more so with
women because they're so fewer women who
are very powerful
in their lives it's so weird to think of
like all the ceos and people we look up
to just getting beat up they all want to
get peed on like lean in to get your
heat on want to get
trampled on they all want to be stepped
on there's step on their head step on
their face my friend that does this um
uh
uh they
what she does is she has to find him in
like at work like in the lobby
like push him into the bathroom and like
humiliate him like he wants to be like
humiliated yeah like you're a piece of
shit like you're disgusting you have a
small dick it's like that kind of stuff
and i'm like is that a
is that a primary caretaker thing is
that a mommy thing is that a
no it what it is is that it's
eroticizing the um
impostor syndrome that they have
so
in general also people who are very
successful in their work and in their
life have a measure of imposter syndrome
so to kind of metabolize that they want
to eroticize it so that's part of it um
when you eroticize um something then it
gives you a kind of ownership over it
mentally and so that's kind of the
the uh what this sort of skeletal
nature of what that is
and then there's all the other stuff on
top of it whether that's mommy issues
whether that's kind of an upbringing
thing whether that's just something that
you saw when you were in your formative
years sexually that
made you really like take notice right
in general that's kind of what
is erotic and what is um
going to be perceived that way for the
rest of their lives you know for your
rest of your sexual life
also as she's saying all this yes she is
holding a bull dick
and i'm holding him gesturing like it's
a
a pointer
you should do doggy dominatrix dog and
nature except
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]